welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of this
podcast and today I'm joined by Greg
Knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being Greg
thanks for joining me how are you doing
today thanks for having me on and I am
doing splendidly how are you I'm doing
great
um let's dive right into it uh the first
thing I want to mention here
um with the podcast is that uh I'm the
first person to admit to your mistakes
and you've done a very poor job so far
uh highlighting the research Spotlight
newsletter that's uh you know when I
bring you on as a guest uh you know
temporary full-time co-host
I need you to pull your weight and not
kind of be there like dead weight I know
you've been jockeying for a more formal
position but uh neglecting your duties
is not a good way to secure that so I'm
going to pick up the slack uh a lot of
people are not yet subscribed I'm going
to interpret those comments as fat
phobic and uh when we get done recording
uh we'll we'll see what HR has to say
about that oh and the union that's going
to be and the union yeah yeah
um so the research Spotlight newsletter
Greg some people aren't subscribed yet
which is crazy uh what you get is a two
minute breakdown of one study every
Wednesday so Greg and I uh you know pick
a study break it down gets into your
email inbox uh every single Wednesday
and the research Spotlight newsletter is
the easiest way to stay up to date with
the latest exercise and nutrition
research the best part Greg it's totally
free completely if there's one thing I
learned in grad school it's that passing
up on free stuff is literally the same
thing as losing money yes okay so as a
grad student I remember I would walk
past a free cup of coffee and I would
know that that is the same thing as
losing somewhere between two and five
dollars if you don't take that free cup
of coffee uh passing on a free lunch
it's literally like getting punched in
the face and having someone take 10 or
15 dollars straight out of your pocket
uh imagine you're offered a free banana
what could a banana cost ten dollars
when if you turn it down it's like
losing ten dollars right out of your
wallet okay so if you want to protect
your net worth and you want to
demonstrate your fiscal responsibility
check out the newsletter you can do that
at Stronger by science.com
newsletter uh of course there are other
ways to support the show as well you can
light rate like rate or subscribe
wherever you happen to get the podcast
you can go to strongerbuyscience.com
coaching to check out our one-on-one
virtual coaching program you can use our
discount code at bulksupplements.com the
code is SBS pod that gets you a five
percent discount of course you could
subscribe to the mass research review
which is a huge research review there's
written articles shorter research briefs
uh video lectures audio round tables
that goes out the first of every single
month and of course you could check out
macro Factor that's our diet app which
does offer a free trial so you can try
it out before you make any kind of
financial commitment
uh another piece of news there is a new
article on the website Greg there is uh
It Is by Cameron Gill he's written a few
very very good articles for our website
uh always a pleasure to be able to host
one of his articles this one is called
neck strength training our deadlifts and
shrugs enough uh and here's just a
little teaser for the article
if you wish to increase neck strength
for a particular sport or neck muscle
size for an aesthetic goal there's no
substitute for direct neck training this
article discusses why and how to
effectively Implement direct neck
training even if you don't have a ton of
fancy equipment to facilitate that
process yes and also I will add since
we're talking about neck training even
just this mention I'm sure that some
people will say in the comments below
the YouTube video or across social media
when we share the podcast episode hey
but with neck training if my neck gets
bigger is that going to give me sleep
apnea I'm not saying that any of of the
individuals listening to this are
responsible for this but when we shared
it on Instagram there were probably it
felt like three dozen comments that were
just like oh but I don't want a good
sleep apnea that's directly addressed in
the article so if that's a concern uh
before before bellyaching about it read
the article uh see if it assuages your
fears uh the the tldr version of that
though is that in all likelihood the
primary contributor to sleep apnea is
tongue size specifically if you have a
large fat or a large neck due to adipose
tissue accumulation
um you also have fat deposits in your
tongue and if you store fat around your
neck you probably also store fat in the
base of your tongue that's probably the
main thing contributing to sleep apnea
uh similar with and this wasn't directly
addressed in the article this is just
kind of me free handing here
um but with people who develop sleep
apnea after they start using steroids
the muscles around their neck blow up
shoulder girdle muscles tend to have a
pretty high density of Androgen
receptors
um in all likelihood that's probably
just due to muscle hypertrophy of the
tongue as well rather than neck muscles
per se it's hard to see like a clear
mechanistic reason that the muscles of
the neck would be able to put much
pressure on the airway passages whereas
Simply Having a bigger tongue would and
tongue size tends to correlate with neck
size rather than neck muscle itself per
se being a major factor
um but anyway that that is addressed in
detail in the article with plenty of
references if you would like to check it
out and otherwise neck training it's
good and cool and having a big neck is
awesome absolutely uh now one last thing
we need to address before we get into
the segments today
I want to talk a little bit about fat
bear week and to kick things off I'm
going to start by playing a couple clips
from from one of our episodes about a
year ago when we were talking about the
results from 2021 fat bear week
bear week is over and bear week is also
canceled
um I have canceled it we have canceled
it the winner uh as they're calling it
was 480 Otis a lot of
I guess I would say irregularities
that's yeah that's [ __ ] yeah so oh my
God needless to say we're upset the fix
was in
I shouldn't have to spell out how
patently unfair that is this fat bear
week uh has left a very a very sour
taste in my mouth and I don't know that
I can ever trust democracy again
so those are some pretty
um pretty poignant quotes and at the
time people said that we were just
haters some people called us conspiracy
theorists but I would say more like
Canary in the coal mine it would be more
appropriate so Greg I'll turn it over to
you um to give a little fat bear week
update yeah I think we're just in a
weird place in our culture where the
people who respect election integrity
and if there are abnormalities they
maybe want recounts or or to look into
it closer those people are are tarred
and feathered as conspiracy theorists
and that's that's really a shame uh we
have we have plenty of uh of packet
captures and whatnot that will be
presented as at a cyber Symposium about
all of all of the fraud that took place
in fat bear week voting uh but yeah this
year there was a I think semi-final
matchup between 747 spoiler alert the
eventual champion uh and was it 480
Holly yeah I think it was Holly yeah
yeah
um and I think people were stuffing the
ballots for Holly and uh that was called
whole graveyards in Cook County were
turning out to vote for Holly uh there
were ballots being shipped over from
North Korea I believe
um just just all sort you know if they
if they required valid forms of voter ID
to vote for fat bear week who knows what
would happen
um anyway uh so yeah that that actually
got caught uh and investigated and uh it
was it was overturned 747 Advanced and
then went on to win the finals so
congratulations to uh 747 for for
winning fat bear week this year
um
I I think I saw someone refer to him as
bareforce1 which is a good pun on on his
number uh sharing uh with with the with
the Boeing model planes uh but yeah so
so congrats to uh to 747 for a
well-deserved uh 2022 fat bear week win
so a quick update I actually think just
in the interest of being when we have
our Symposium obviously we'll go our
ducks in a row here but I believe I
think I think they found bamboo in some
of the ballots from Arizona wow
um maybe maybe fake ballads from China
you never know well uh it looks like the
some of the uh fraudulent votes were for
Bear 435 so I don't want to disparage uh
the fans of holly or Otis or any of the
other uh upstanding Bears who who of
course would have nothing to do with
this kind of Scandal uh but yeah I
believe it was uh bear 435 and you know
435 has a reputation as I don't have to
explain yeah
so anyway uh really sad to see that um
and hopefully they can clean up their
act and uh you know we kind of caught on
to it about a year before everyone else
but hopefully by next year they can kind
of improve the Integrity of their
operations
uh all right Greg let's get into some
Fitness stuff uh what do you got for us
this week
so uh my segment is on increasing
explosiveness and training to maximize
jump height in particular but probably
most sort of explosive movements in
general
um
and uh yeah the the one weird trick that
I'm going to talk about is training with
accommodating resistance or uh for for
people who haven't spent much time with
the West Side barbell parlance just
training with bands or chains so
um just just for some very very basic
background for people who have not
trained with bands or chains before
aren't very familiar with accommodating
resistance uh basically it's just a
different way to add resistance to a
variety of exercises but primarily what
I'm thinking about here is barbell
exercises Beyond just putting more
plates on the bar uh and so when you add
plates on the bar you know the barbell
is 45 pounds you slap some 45s on now
it's 135 pounds and uh that's just due
to gravity which is pulling straight
down all the time and whatever you
whatever lift you do uh at all points in
the range of motion there will be 135
pounds of resistance you have to
overcome that's that's just what the
weight is with accommodating resistance
uh if you hang some like thick elastic
rubber bands Over the Bar those bands
behave as a hooke's law spring wood or
in other words as they're stretched the
resistance they provide increases
linearly so at the bottom of a squat for
example the bands might provide 40
pounds of resistance and at the top they
may provide 80 pounds of resistance and
right in the middle guess what they'd
provide 60 pounds of resistance so it
allows for variable resistance
throughout the range of motion and
chains behave similar similarly you can
hang chains from the bar generally off
of a smaller chain so that when you're
at the bottom of a lift most of the
chains are on the ground and then at the
top of the lift most of the chains are
off of the ground so for example if you
put 100 pounds of chains on the bar at
say the bottom of a bench press maybe
you're feeling 250 pounds with all of
the chains on the ground and and then
when you lock it out you're now filling
350 pounds because those hundred pounds
of chains have come off of the ground
um
so yeah with with accommodating
resistance you can vary the amount of
resistance you're dealing with
throughout the range of motion and in
particular it makes the lifts a little
bit easier at the bottom a little bit
harder at the top uh Eric have you ever
done much or any training with bands or
chains oh hell yeah hell yeah I mean
what what's your what's your go-to or
what's your favorite it kind of it
didn't really matter dude uh so when I
first got into
um coaching
um like like you know working as a
strength coach I was working with a
wrestling team and a football team and I
had all the gym access I could ever want
and it was a really well equipped gym I
would go in there I was you know 18 19
20 years old and just put chains on
literally everything because it was so
badass oh absolutely dips pull-ups just
throwing like could have easily used any
other mode of resistance but I was like
no dude put the chain around my neck
yeah uh but yeah I would do
um you know oh rack chins are kind of
like you know inverted body weight rows
with some chains I would do uh bench
press with chains I would just any
excuse to get them in the mix I would
use it yeah that's that's completely
valid so I I also love chains I
personally don't like bands all that
much
um
not because I think they're ineffective
I just I just don't like how they make
lifts feel but that and they're to me
they were always a pain in the ass to
set up I I agree it's hard to find two
bands that have like the exact same
amount of resistance so the bar feels
like a little bit uneven
um but anyway yeah love chains anything
with chains they're one they're loud and
I like I like things that are loud uh
you're lifting like you're working out
makes you sound like Jacob Marley which
is very cool uh one of one of the best
characters in in all of fiction and
literature
um
and yeah like I I really enjoy the way
they make most most strength curves feel
um but yeah so that's that's what we're
going to be talking about here for for
the purpose not so much of trying to Max
my strength gains but trying to maximize
gains in Explosive Performance and like
I said specifically jump height
so
I I actually got in trouble uh couple
months ago uh when talking about
accommodating resistance I was on Dave
Tate's table Talk podcast and this topic
came up
um and I mentioned that like hey the the
research tends to suggest that for
specifically maximizing gains in raw
strength like say trying to maximize
gains in barbell squat one rep max or
barbell bench press one rep max uh
training with accommodating resistance
does seem to be effective for strength
gains but doesn't seem to be more
effective than just training with
straight weight
um which in most uh sectors of the
powerlifting Community is is a pretty
uncontroversial opinion
um but there are a lot of like big time
old school West Side fans in in the
table talk audience uh they didn't
particularly like that perspective which
is totally fair uh but I will note that
the that the research and also just like
the training practices of the current
best raw power lifters on the planet
agree with me so on the on the power
lifter side I mean there are a ton of
extremely strong raw power lifters out
there uh and if you stalk them on social
media to see how they train you just
don't see that many folks training with
bands or chains a ton anymore again
specifically for for raw power lifting
accommodating resistance for
specifically strength development does
make a lot of sense for equip lifting
because it allows you to experience a
strength curve that or like a resistance
curve that is a little more similar to
what you'd be dealing with with equipped
power lifting because like a bench shirt
squat suit helps you more at the bottom
of the lift than the top of a lift so if
you don't want to have to deal with
getting into all of your gear but you
still want a similar uh training
experience you can set up accommodating
resistance to kind of mimic that but for
raw lifting
um yeah I mean you just don't see that
many top raw lifters doing a ton of
training with bands or chains these days
and on the research side of things in
2015 there was a meta-analysis published
by Soria Gila and colleagues uh
suggesting that training with
accommodating resistance did in fact uh
improve strength gains to a larger
extent than training with straight
weight but then in 2018 another group of
researchers led by dos Santos
um
like I I think these I think these folks
were just planning on doing a study uh
like looking at the effects of of bands
or chains on strength development so
they're they're like okay let's kind of
get our feet wet in this research let's
pull up this meta-analysis see what it
found and then they started looking
through the meta-analysis and said I
think they may have accidentally
miscalculated some of these effect sizes
so they wrote in and said hey I think
there were some errors here uh and and
to the credit of Soria Gila and
colleagues
um they looked back and said yep you got
us like we we made a mistake uh so that
that has now been updated and the the
pooled effect is like yeah straight
weight is effective bands and chains are
effective uh training with accommodating
resistance doesn't seem to be more
effective than just training with
straight weight though it does still
work
um do you think that might be the only
exercise science meta with an error
foreign
don't want to get too far off topic but
we we should probably talk about that
that paper we will at some point but for
people that are listening we won't get
into it but there's there was a paper I
think last week or the week before that
was published indicating they're like
yeah we went through a bunch of metas
and like exercising Sports Science and I
think they said 85 had a statistical
error at least one yeah yeah uh which is
both knots that was very unsurprising to
us yeah um but I think it would be
surprising to a lot of people but yeah
it's certainly not what you'd like to
see right yeah but anyway sorry to
interrupt with that tangent but but yeah
so uh training with accommodating
resistance in terms of one rep max raw
strength development doesn't seem to be
all that beneficial again it's good it
works fine it just doesn't seem to work
better than training with straight
weight uh and there's good good reason
to kind of
suspect that it wouldn't be better than
straight weight and and the reason for
that
is just for most exercises if you're
doing a one rep max specifically barbell
lifts generally
you're not your your strength your one
rep max isn't going to be limited by how
strong you are through the entire range
of motion it's limited by how strong you
are through the very weakest point in
the range of motion which is usually
pretty early on in the concentric phase
or near the bottom of most lifts
um and in fact it's it's even earlier on
than I think a lot of people realize
most people assume the weakest point in
say a squad or a bench press is when the
bar is moving the slowest but it's
actually not it's when the bar is
decelerating because force is mass times
acceleration and so if acceleration is
negative that means there's less Force
output so if you're like if the bar is
still like moving at the same relatively
slow velocity that means the force
you're exerting is uh either equal to or
greater than the load on the barbell if
the bar is actively decelerating that
means at that moment in time you're
exerting less Force than the force being
exerted by the bar barbell so yeah like
the weakest point in the lift is even
before like what is commonly defined as
the sticking point so it's it's low down
there that's that's where your weakest
and most lifts and so that's what's
determining performance and the way that
uh the way that bands and chains work
it's like I mentioned before a band
stretches as you go up more chains come
off the ground as you go up so it makes
the lift harder near the top of the lift
which is totally fine but like generally
that's not the part of the range of
motion that's going to dictate what your
one rep max is it's more about can you
create enough Force there at the bottom
of the lift or you're the weakest
um
and so like yeah I mean there there's
every reason to think that training with
bands and chains are probably better for
building strength through the top part
of the lift than training with straight
weight would be but that's not going to
influence one rep max strength all that
much and training with both straight
weight and accommodating resistance
should be equally efficacious for
increasing strength at the bottom of the
lift like as long as you get the loading
right so the those results I think are
are pretty intuitive
um
so yeah that's that's not all that
surprising but with Explosive
Performance the calculus is a little bit
different and and this is where we're
getting into like the actual thrust of
this segment so with Explosive
Performance it's it's a completely
different ball game because it's not
about how strong you are through the
very weakest point in the lift for
something like jumping it's about how
much force can you put through the
ground for the entire duration of the
time your feet are on the ground and so
if you're getting a lot of velocity
going your feet aren't going to be on
the ground very long
um you know you drop down Boop pop right
back up pretty quick and so for that
short period of time for the entire
duration of the time your feet are on
the ground you need to be putting as
much force through the floor as possible
to accelerate your center of mass and as
soon as your feet hit leave the ground
uh the velocity your center of mass has
at that point of takeoff will directly
determine how high you're going to jump
um because you you are no longer putting
more Force into the floor therefore an
upward force on yourself as soon as your
feet leave the ground gravity takes over
and your takeoff velocity just like
one-to-one determines how high you're
going to jump and so you need to
accelerate as much as possible during
that entire time of during that entire
time span you have available to you and
therefore strength and power output
through that entire range of motion is
now very very important like if you can
exert a lot of force in deep knee and
hip flexion that's cool but if you can
also exert a lot of force with very
little knee and hip flexion right before
takeoff that is equally beneficial so
essentially if if there are two people
who have Who weigh the exact same amount
they have like similar fiber types like
you you equate everything between these
two individuals and they squat the same
amount through a full range of motion
but one of them squats way more or for
like a half squad or quarter squat than
the other one does you should expect
that individual with the higher half
Squat and quarter Squat and same full
squat to jump higher than the other
person because they have similar Force
output through that weak part of the
range of motion but through the stronger
part of the range of motion that second
individual is stronger can exert more
Force
Etc
and so
as I mentioned before a benefit of of
training with accommodating resistance
is you can better match the resistance
curve of an exercise with your natural
strength curve so you know for example
if you can bench press
225 pounds or like 100 kilos that
basically means that you can exert about
ah
I'm I'm going to use kilos as a force
measurement I realize they're not but
you get the point that means you can
exert about a hundred kilos of force
where you're the weakest but at the top
maybe you can exert 120 kilos of Force
if you're just training with a barbell
you're stuck with 100 kilos you can't go
heavier than that you'd fail the lift uh
with bands or chains on the other hand
you could potentially set it up to where
you know maybe you have 90 kilos on the
bar and 20 kilos in bands and chains or
something like that it's 90 kilos at the
bottom it's a little bit easier but then
it's 110 kilos at the top so it's it's
matching that it's matching the
resistance curve of the of the lift to
your natural strength curve a little bit
better so even though that's not going
to be extra beneficial for improving
your one rep max that probably will be
extra beneficial for increasing strength
throughout that entire range of motion
uh and and if you're watching on YouTube
um there there's a figure that we can
Flash up on the screen now that that
kind of illustrates how this works how
with accommodating resistance you can
make sure that that the lifts you're
doing are
challenging through a larger relative
proportion of the entire range of motion
you're training through and so for that
purpose just kind kind of on an a priori
basis you should expect that training
with accommodating resistance should be
better for improving Explosive
Performance and in fact that is what we
see when we look at the literature and
I'll also note it's it's a little
surprising how little research there is
on this topic
um just because a lot of times practical
application guides research to some
extent like there's a bit of a give and
take like research guides practical
application and practical application
guides research if there are a lot of
coaches doing something specific in the
gym with their athletes some of those
athletes are going to become Master
students in exercise science and realize
like hey the stuff that my coaches were
doing uh I don't think there's research
on that I'm going to do that as a
master's project so there's kind of that
feedback loop
um and bands and chains are just you
know it from a quote unquote in the
trenches perspective are used pretty
frequently for for training athletes at
all levels of sport from uh like you're
not going to see them in many high
school weight rooms but like training
facilities that specialize in training
high school athletes like off the clock
or out of school will will often use
bands and chains uh plenty of college
weight rooms use bands and chains for a
lot of stuff like you mentioned before
um
so yeah this is a pretty common thing in
practice but I was only able to find
four particular studies that have
examined uh this so comparing training
with straight weight versus training
with bands or chains and all of these
studies use bands
um on uh gains and Explosive Performance
and in particularly jump height here so
uh to start with a study by She and
colleagues Shi and as a note mention
this every time all of the studies I
cite will be linked in the show notes so
starting with a study by She and
colleagues the subjects in the study
were Collegiate basketball players who
uh were were pretty well trained to
start with as far as Collegiate
basketball players go average one rep
max Squad was like 125 kilos which for
tall [ __ ] like that's not bad
um and they they completed an eight-week
training program one group just trained
with straight weights the other group
trained with a combination of straight
weights and bands and the the resistance
provided by the bands in the band group
was equal to 35 percent of 1rm at the
top of the lift and very very little at
the bottom of the lift
um so the amount of load on the bar that
was replaced was equal to about about 17
percent of one RM to equalize average
loading between the two groups so just
to illustrate if a subject had a 200
kilo Squat and I'm just using that to to
make the numbers easy
um so let's say a subject had a 200 kilo
Squat and in a particular workout
they're going to be training with 80 of
1rm so that's 160 kilos so in the group
that was just training with straight
weight you would just do reps with 160
kilos in the band group in this
particular study uh what they would
first do is remove
um
uh that they would add an amount of
bands that was equal to 35 of 1rm which
in this case would be 70 kilos 200 times
0.35 about 70. uh and then they would
um replace uh a portion of that so in
effect
um
like you would want it to be an average
of 160 kilos throughout the entire uh
portion of the lift so it would be
um I think they would put
125 yeah so it would be 125 kilos on the
bar plus the 70 kilos of bands so it'd
be like 125 at the bottom 195 at the top
average out to 160. so that like I did a
poor job explaining that but that that's
what they did hopefully hopefully that
makes sense
um so yeah they train like that for
eight weeks and ultimately squatting
with bands and squatting with straight
weight as one would expect from the rest
of the literature uh led to similar
increases in one RM squat strength which
again is which what we should expect
um but squatting with the bands did lead
to larger increases in squat jump
Improvement and counter movement jump
Improvement so it was like 21 1.4
percent versus 12.9 percent for squat
jump and 12.9 versus 5.6 for counter
movement jump oh but the p-value was
.056 so that doesn't really I mean it's
not below 0.05 makes you think wow well
okay let's just go with squat Jump Then
which was a p of 0.008 I'm being a smart
ass obviously I I don't subscribe to
that nitpicking uh with regards to P
values
yeah 12.9 percent is uh bigger than 5.6
percent I I agree with that assessment
um okay so so that was uh the first
study there were two more that had
broadly similar results so one was by
katushabe and Kramer and the other was
by joy and colleagues in the study by
katushabe and Kramer uh the subjects
were male soccer players they trained
for six weeks
um again one group with bands one group
with straight weights they found that
squatting with bands led to at least
nominally larger uh increases in Jump
height than training with straight
weight so about 2.67 centimeters versus
about 1.38 and then in the study by joy
and colleagues uh the subjects were
again Collegiate basketball players uh
completing a five-week training program
one group squatting with combination of
bands and straight weights the other
group uh just squatting with straight
weight
um and they looked at two measures of a
vertical jump performance they measured
vertical jump height on both a force
plate so like using an equation to
estimate
um like how much like how high people
jumped from their ground reaction forces
during the actual jumping movement and
then also just a more direct assessment
of jump height using a vertek and if
memory serves in the study the vertek
jump height Improvement there was a
nominal difference between groups so it
was like a 6.3 percent increase in the
band group versus like a 4.1 percent
increase in the straight weight group I
don't think that was a statistically
significant difference and then for the
the force plate assessment uh it was
like plus 7.5 percent in the band group
and like minus 1.8 percent uh in the
straight weight group and if memory
serves that was a statistically
significant difference but like I said
all like all of the the nominal
differences I mean lean in favor of of
squatting with bands and all of these
studies uh however the fourth study uh
by Anderson and colleagues in this
little body of literature uh did come to
different results so uh the subjects in
that study were trained women they
completed 10 weeks of training again one
group squatting with bands uh or a
combination of bands and straight
weights and the other group uh just
squatting with straight weight and they
assessed counter movement jump height
um with uh
like like basically different knee
angles to start with so like how far you
would descend uh for the counter
movement before jumping back up so they
looked at kind of like a a two kind of
normal uh ranges of motion for jump so
through 60 and 90 degrees of knee
flexion that's around how much most
people would Flex their knees before a
jump and then they also looked at like
what if you just did a really really
deep counter movement before you jumped
um so down to about 120 degrees of knee
flexion and what they found is that at
least in terms of nominal differences
gains in Jump height at 60 degrees of
knee flexion were pretty similar uh
between the two training approaches uh
leaned slightly in favor of squatting
with bands but then at 90 degrees and
120 degrees those nominal differences
leaned in favor of squatting with
straight weight so essentially we have
three studies that tend to find benefits
in favor of training with accommodating
resistance and we have one study that
found at least a deeper levels of knee
flexion some some benefits may be of
squatting with straight weight so what
could potentially explain the the
different results between these three
studies and I think the biggest
difference is just how much of the total
resistance came from bands so in the
three studies that tended to find
benefits of squatting with bands the
ones by she joy and catashabe and Kramer
the bands replaced about 15 to 20
percent of the total load on the bar
with the total band resistance equaling
about 30 to 40 percent of one RM at the
top
um
and for the Anderson study the the total
band tension used and therefore the
amount of actual weight replaced by
bands was like twice that large so it
was a a relatively enormous amount of
band tension used in that study so like
that that kind of makes sense
intuitively right so in the Anderson
study they found that through deeper
levels of knee flexion squatting with a
ton of band tension maybe wasn't great
for improving jump height but if you
have a ton of band tension on the bar
effectively you're just making the very
bottom of the lift very easy so what you
should be going for and I think what
three of the four studies in this area
accomplished is with accommodating
resistance instead of a kind of
traditional strength curve or resistance
curve you'd see with straight weight
where the bottom of the lift is hard and
the top is easy what you want to do with
the amount of accommodating resistance
you use is you basically want want the
entire lift to be similarly challenging
throughout you want the bottom to be
challenging you want the top to be
challenging train that entire range of
motion I think what happened in the
Anderson study is they used so much band
tension they inverted that typical
resistance curve where instead of now
being hard at the bottom and easy at the
top I think they just made it very easy
at the bottom and hard at the top so
there was less transference to jump
height at deeper degrees of knee flexion
um
so yeah uh overall the this uh body of
literature and also just kind of the the
logical reasoning I I laid out at the
start of this segment all suggest that
training with bands should and does uh
improve jump height and Explosive
Performance likely to a greater extent
than just training with straight weight
would
um which makes sense you match the
strength and resistance curves better
you build more strength through a longer
total percentage of the range of motion
you're training through uh and that
should help you exert Force through the
floor through a larger total range of
motion before your feet leave the ground
so you're not just strong at the bottom
you're strong through that entire range
of motion and that should be beneficial
for Explosive Performance
um like I said all of this stuff uses
bands uh rather than chains and it's all
mostly just looking at Jump performance
so I assume that these are probably
generalizable findings like I assume
that uh if you subbed out bands for
chains it would still be beneficial
because you're still matching strength
Curves in the same way like what they
accomplished with bands in these studies
you can also accomplish with chains uh I
don't see a reason why binging with
bands or doing deadlifts with bands
wouldn't or chains wouldn't have similar
effects through those ranges of motion
and general movement patterns like
um you know if you're trying to build
explosive hip hinging strength like dead
lifting with accommodating resistance
should be pretty good we just don't have
research on it
um
but yeah so I assume these findings
generalize I just don't know for sure
another note is that the gains and
explosiveness in these studies were were
pretty specific so I I made specific
note of talking about the gains in
vertical jump performance uh and the
various sorts of jump tests you do mimic
the mechanics of squatting pretty well
but uh several of these studies also
looked at gains in Sprint performance or
gains in Agility Test performance uh and
for those measures uh training with
bands didn't seem to be more beneficial
than training with straight weight once
again like with one rep max strength it
wasn't that it was less beneficial than
training with straight weight it still
worked
um there just wasn't like in additive
additional benefit so
you know like it it
seems like maybe training with bands
will help you jump higher but might not
actually like improve Sprint performance
or change of Direction performance uh to
a greater extent than training with
straight weight which again to be very
clear means it's still good it's just
not better uh and then
finally uh for for loading
recommendations I think that
um
I think that the the three studies were
training with bands worked are probably
a pretty good starting point so in in
all three of those studies uh the amount
of band tension used was equal to about
30 to 40 percent of one RM uh replacing
an amount of straight weight resistance
equal to about 15 to 20 percent of one
RM so that that seems to be a pretty
good starting point so for example like
if you're one rep max squat is 100 kilos
and a workout would typically involve
squatting with 80 kilos for sets of five
you could instead do 60 kilos with 40 or
yeah 60 kilos with 40 kilos of band
tension or 65 kilos with 30 kilos of
band tension so the average resistance
throughout the range of motion would
would average out to the 80 kilos you
you'd be otherwise training with but
that should help match your the
resistance curve of the exercise with
your strength curve a little bit better
by again subbing out about 30 to 40
percent one rep max amount of resistance
with with bands or chains
um
and then also just as kind of a final
party note is intent matters uh intent
matters a lot with with any power
training whether you're whether you're
using accommodating resistance or just
training with straight weight
um you want to really be trying to
aggressively accelerate the bar as much
as possible through as much of the range
of motion as possible which I'll also
note is just another benefit of training
with accommodating resistance like if if
you're doing explosive bench press with
just the bar
at lockout the bar has to come to a stop
like if you have any reasonable amount
of load on the bar
you don't want the bar to leave your
hands that's dangerous like that's
that's bad and so a a decent percentage
at the end of the concentric is going to
be spent just decelerating the bar like
you're not actively trying to push
through lockout
um
because if you did the bar would either
leave your hands or there would just be
like so much inertia in the bar it would
like pull your back up off of the bench
that's happened to me [ __ ] up the rest
of the set not good you don't want that
going on similar with squats like if you
really try to accelerate all the way
through the concentric with straight
weight as you would if you were jumping
guess what's going to happen you're
gonna jump and like jump squats exist
but if you're you know if your heels
leave the ground or the bar comes up off
your shoulders a little bit with like 70
percent of one RM especially if you're
not ready for it that could be a little
bit hazardous one of the one of the
benefits of bands and chains is just
since the weights getting heavier and
heavier as you proceed through the
concentric you can just actively
accelerate through a larger portion of
the concentric before you have to
decelerate their lockout so that's good
and and also I mean especially with
bands
I don't know exactly why it feels
different than chains but like it does
like when bands hit you they hit you
hard uh and like on squat they try to
slingshot you through the floor
um so I think like I think like a
low-key benefit of of power training
with bands is just like they sort of
force you to be really really aggressive
with every rep because
if you don't if you don't generate
velocity out of the hole like when they
hit you you're gonna feel it
um but yeah for for any power training
whether you're training with bands or
chains or just straight weight uh intent
matters like you you really want to try
to accelerate the bar as aggressively as
possible through as much of the range of
motion as possible but uh like I
mentioned bands and chains do help you
facilitate doing that just just based on
how they they change the resistance
curve yeah this is not directly related
uh to vertical jump and you know power
and things like that but I will say uh
covid related gym shutdowns completely
change my relationship with bands uh for
the longest time I was like oh those
those things are kind of a pain in the
ass to set up and and all this stuff and
and then covet hit and Man Without bands
I don't know how I would have gotten
through that as a person who lifts and
as a as a a coach yeah like who man uh
bands really came through when I needed
them and I will forever be appreciative
so yeah chains and bands are always
going to be on the good side for me
chains because they're very cool and
badass and bands because when you're in
a pinch especially if you're training at
home uh they they really do expand what
you can do oh for sure one one other
thing I'll note not related to improving
explosiveness gem performance whatever
but just just kind of like a a low-key
benefit especially of training with
chains
um and especially for folks who've been
Lifting for kind of a long time and are
like maybe sort of beat up uh so like I
mentioned with the Anderson study for
strength development for power
development you don't want to like fully
invert that resistance curve where now
instead of being hard at the bottom easy
at the top it becomes easy at the bottom
hard at the top like that that's
probably not the best way to set them up
purely for improving performance but uh
if you maybe have achy hips or achy
shoulders
and you get some like range of motion
related discomfort on like bench press
where
you know if if you're if you have pretty
heavy weight on the bar your shoulders
just your shoulders or elbows just
really don't like you much specifically
at the bottom of of the press uh but you
also don't want to just take 70 of the
weight off the bar and just train light
all the time like that's not fun you
don't want to do it uh something you can
do which like I've done and I know a lot
of older lifters do this
um is you can just put a shitload of
chains on the bar so now like the bench
is easy at the bottom where where maybe
your shoulders aren't quite as happy
with you but it just like gets hard and
heavy as you press it so you can still
feel heavy weight in your hands you can
still like really exert yourself not
have to do like 40 reps per set with a
super low load but still
um you know give give some of those soft
tissues that aren't super happy with you
a little bit of a break from the from
the really heavy loading
um that that's another just like very
nice thing you can you can unlock with
accommodating resistance yeah for sure
all right you ready to move on yeah
let's do it awesome so I've got a
segment today uh about energy
compensation exercise energy
compensation so this is a topic that we
are revisiting we've covered it before
uh but a couple things have changed
first of all now we have graphical
capabilities I can actually insert
images on the YouTube presentation
that'll make these things uh these
Concepts a little bit more tangible uh
and now we also have a brand new tool on
the macro Factor uh website that makes
this information a little bit more
accessible but more importantly a little
bit more actionable you know you can
actually put this stuff to use now so I
figured it was a good time to revisit
the concept and first of all someone
might be asking what is exercise energy
compensation and I think that's actually
best answered by looking at a a bit of a
problem in the research uh something
that's come up time and time again and
to address this problem in the research
I want to lean on
an article a mass article that the good
doctor Eric Helms wrote for mass and
it's been you know we've talked about it
before I don't like the guy but I still
appreciate his work you know uh and I
try to stay impartial in that regard I I
was going to ask if we'd squash the beef
but uh definitely not sounds like we
haven't and that that's the way I like
it if anything it's getting it's
intensifying good you know yeah
um but you know don't like the guy but
he's done some good things I have to
give him that so his article was called
why do you flee the country and run
Halfway Around the World to New Zealand
like it it may it makes you wonder what
he's trying to get away from it does
make you wonder it makes it makes me
wonder a lot and I'm I got people
looking into it it should make more
people wonder yeah just throwing that
out there yeah and where was he when all
this fat bear week voting was going on
I don't know inquiring minds want to
know yeah so anyway his article was
called why cardio isn't as effective for
fat loss as you'd expect and that pretty
much lays out the problem people have
looked at
a bunch of different uh controlled
interventions using cardio as a fat loss
tool and results have been uh I think
it's safe to say pretty underwhelming so
in this particular article he was
reviewing a paper by Broski and
colleagues which was called effective
aerobic exercise induced weight loss on
the components of daily energy
expenditure that's a great name Broski
Broski it is a good name now in this
study they had 42 participants they were
individuals with obesity and they were
put into three groups one was basically
a control group one was an aerobic
exercise group that was doing a lower
amount of total weekly exercise so they
were trying to burn eight kilocalories
per kilogram of body weight per week so
they were kind of tailoring the exercise
dose accordingly and then there is also
this higher expenditure group who is
shooting for 20 kilocalories per
kilogram of weight per week
um so they were they were doing this
intervention they were also looking at a
whole bunch of metrics pertaining to
energy expenditure so uh The Cliff Notes
I'll put up a table that shows some of
the more detailed uh results of the
intervention but the cliff notes is the
high expenditure group uh they did lose
a signific a statistically significant
amount of body weight but it was only
half the amount that would be expected
mathematically if you basically crunch
the numbers and said how many calories
were they supposed to burn off with this
exercise dose it basically only
delivered about half of the
mathematically anticipated weight loss
they also found that their total daily
energy expenditure increased by about
four percent driven by by the increase
in exercise but when they brought them
into a metabolic chamber and directly
measured their energy expenditure for 24
hours
of course in that at rest right at rest
yeah so I was going to say of course in
that chamber they weren't exercising
yeah uh when they took it from free
living conditions and said okay without
the added influence of that exercise
what's your kind of just basal resting
energy expenditure like resting not
basil over this 24-hour period and it
actually decreased by four percent it
appeared that there was a kind of a
compensatory change in other
non-exercise elements of energy
expenditure uh now the lower dose group
that was doing less exercise uh their uh
body weight was not reduced to a
statistically significant uh degree so
uh basically what they concluded there
was that uh aerobic exercise at this
higher dose uh was able to produce
weight loss but it was less weight loss
than expected which appeared to be
related to some kind of compensatory
reduction in non-exercise elements of
energy expenditure so that brings me to
a model that really is at the center of
the conversation about exercise energy
compensation so
Herman ponzer is a researcher down the
road at Duke and he has really
popularized this idea uh of the
constrained total energy expenditure
model and I'm going to put up a figure
that kind of demonstrates what this
model proposes but but a lot of
sponsor's early work was looking at
total daily energy expenditure in
different societies with very different
physical activity levels and one of the
things he noticed was you know you know
I mentioned in the previous study by
Broski they kind of did a mathematical
Assumption of how much weight ought to
be lost and going into that model is the
or going into those calculations is the
Assumption of the additive model which
if you're watching on YouTube you'll see
it on the left side of the screen but
the idea with the additive model is very
simple it's basically if you add some
exercise to your routine and you add
maybe 200 calories per day of exercise
then your total energy expenditure will
go up by 200 calories if you add 300
calories of exercise total energy
expenditure will go up by 300 calories
right it's a very very straightforward
thing
now the constrained model which you'll
see on the right side of your screen if
you're watching on YouTube this paints a
different picture now what this
indicates is that as you increase more
and more exercise or other types of
physical activity total daily energy
expenditure will go up but at a certain
point you start to get some diminishing
returns it looks like there's some kind
of sealing effect some kind of
constraint on energy expenditure when
physical activity levels get really
really high and one of the things that
is playing into that apparent ceiling
effect is it appears to be some adaptive
changes in non-exercise components of
energy expenditure so as the model
dictates as you go as you start ramping
physical activity up and up and up and
up and get to really high levels there
will be compensatory reductions in other
you know more resting components of
energy expenditure that that basically
those adaptive changes appear to just
offset the tremendous energy cost of
this added activity and it you could
kind of take it back to evolutionary uh
mechanisms and theories about why it
might be disadvantageous for us to just
kind of scale up energy expenditure more
and more and more as we have high
activity levels you could imagine in a
in an environment in which food is
scarce and you might have increased
activity for uh for foraging Gathering
hunting whatever the case may be it
might be uh helpful in some cases for
there to be some constraint on how much
your energy expenditure ramps up yeah
now and and also to be clear for the
people who are are listening to this
can't see the model uh on on screen it's
also like proposed to be a pretty
dose-dependent thing right absolutely
that's a good point like if you're
currently incredibly sedentary don't
exercise at all and start you know just
going for a daily walk and burning 100
calories through exercise that might
lead to a 100 calorie increase in your
total daily energy expenditure but if
you're already very active exercising a
lot burning a thousand calories per day
through exercise and you add 10 more
exercise to where now you're burning
1100 calories per day through exercise
like you're going from from high to even
higher that 100 calorie increase in
exercise since you're already quite
active will lead to an increase in total
daily energy expenditure likely
considerably smaller than 100 calories
yeah so like it the constrained model
behaves very similarly to the additive
model if you're going from sedentary to
lightly active to like moderately active
maybe but if you're going from like
moderately active to very active or like
very active to extremely active then
some more of those adaptive mechanisms
set in to where you have reductions in
or larger reductions in in other
components of total energy expenditure
correct yeah and that's a good point and
there's really two main misconceptions
that are that have picked up a lot of
steam and a lot of people uh kind of
reinforce these misconceptions
unintentionally and so they've kind of
been popularized but uh the the first
misconception is the one that you just
mentioned which is that you know a lot
of people just completely ignore the
fact that this is a dose dependent
non-linear thing that's happening right
so like you said as you go higher and
higher into really high levels of
physical activity the compensatory
reductions and other components of
energy expenditure get increasingly
larger and larger
um so so that's the one thing the other
misconception which is probably the more
impactful one is is people seem to
indicate that the level of uh
compensation here you know the amount of
energy that's being offset by these
adaptive reductions and other
non-exercise components people seem to
reinforce the idea that the compensation
level is 100 like I've heard a lot of
people
who have said you cannot increase your
total daily energy expenditure through
exercise yeah because if you increase
you know 100 calories of exercise you're
just going to decrease 100 calories of
other stuff yeah it is very important to
to note that that is absolutely not what
this model indicates if you look at how
it's depicted by the person who created
it and more importantly it's not what
the data underlying the model indicate
exactly yeah the much more important
element is that people keep spreading
this idea as if we can't just look at
actual papers that have measured this
stuff yeah and the compensation level
is simply not a hundred percent uh it is
is well below 100 but that brings us to
kind of the
the main question here in this segment
which is well what is the magnitude of
compensation and just to be super clear
when I talk about the magnitude of
compensation I'm talking about you know
to what what percentage of this increase
in exercise energy expenditure is being
offset by compensatory reductions and
other components of total daily energy
expenditure so
the magnitude of compensation if you're
asking what is it well it's not a
hundred percent
but unfortunately it turns out to be
quite variable from person to person and
from Context to context so I wish that I
could say hey it's not 100 it's 30. but
I I can't really say that uh because
it's extremely context dependent and it
does vary a lot among individuals so
there are a few key characteristics that
we can look at when we're trying to
figure out okay well for me or maybe for
my client that I'm coaching what is a
reasonable expectation for the magnitude
of compensation and and just to just to
make make all of this very explicit
because I think sometimes people get
confused when you're throwing out
percentages it's like ah percentage of
what so just to be like very very
explicit to say that 30 compensation
occurs implies that if you burn 100
calories from exercise 30 of those
calories won't kind of contribute to
increase cases in total daily energy
expenditure so thirty percent
compensation means if exercise increases
by 100 calories total daily energy
expenditure increases by 70 calories
correct so like a higher compensation
number means a smaller increase in total
daily energy expenditure as exercise
increases a smaller compensation number
means a larger increase in total daily
energy expenditure as exercise increases
exactly so yeah for that 100 calories
worth of exercise example uh if you're
doing that 100 calories of extra
exercise and it's a 10 compensation
value your you know total daily energy
expenditure goes up by 90 calories if
it's a 50 compensation value then total
daily energy expenditure only goes up by
50 calories yeah
um so one of the things that a lot of
people have kind of speculated about is
does this vary based on biological sex
you know does it seem to differ a lot
when we compare males to females and
there is a paper by Caro and colleagues
it's the best evidence available to date
to actually explore that question and
the answer appears to be no it doesn't
seem like there's kind of a systematic
bias by which compensation levels differ
when we compare males to females for
this particular outcome as we've
mentioned previously you know people
have asked does it differ depending on
your total activity level absolutely so
if you are someone who like you said
earlier has a very low Baseline activity
level
and you're just adding a little bit of
exercise you can anticipate a low
compensation value which means you're
getting the most bang for your buck if
you're increasing physical activity and
hoping to increase total daily energy
expenditure uh if you're someone who is
extremely active already uh then you can
expect a much larger compensation factor
which again means that the exercise that
you're adding is having a a more
constrained or restricted impact on
total daily energy expenditure so
activity level absolutely plays a big
role another thing that plays a big role
apparently seems to be energy balance so
I'm going to put an image on the screen
here this is from a paper by Willis and
colleagues but they were interested in
looking at using a big sample of
participants with really high quality
measurements they had WWE labeled water
data accessible for this particular
study they were looking at essentially
the degree of compensation and how that
varies for people who are in negative
neutral or positive energy balance so
you know neutral energy balance means
you're just eating at maintenance
basically staying pretty weight stable
negative energy balance means you're in
a caloric deficit and so over time you
could expect to be losing weight and
positive energy balance means you're in
an energy Surplus which means over a
longer time scale you could expect to
gain weight now for people who are in
neutral or positive energy balance the
additive model did just fine so again
the additive model basically assumes
minimal compensation technically it
assumes zero compensation so what what
that tells us is people in neutral and
positive energy balance the compensation
value is quite low such that the
additive model did just fine uh in terms
of of kind of uh you know predicting how
total energy expenditure would change or
what kind of compensation level we would
anticipate uh however looking
specifically at people in negative
energy balance so people who were in an
energy deficit uh the constrained model
did a better job explaining the data
when compared to the additive model so
what that tells us is for someone who's
in negative energy balance we can expect
that it will essentially increase the
degree to which they compensate for an
increase in exercise energy expenditure
so smaller compensation values for
people in neutral or positive energy
balance larger compensation values for
people in negative energy balance
one final consideration or
characteristic that comes up a lot in
this research is BMI
now there was a the study I mentioned
previously by Caro and colleagues uh
excellent study and a really really nice
data set that they're working with uh it
it's the doubly labeled water database
um I forget the acronym of who houses it
it's like the international
atomic energy agency or something like
that I I believe that's correct yeah but
anyway huge database there have been a
lot of great papers coming out of it
lately uh really impressive
collaborative multi-center effort which
is what we need in the research world so
the reason I keep uh kind of like
gushing about it is because it really is
a a tremendous utility for the research
World
um but anyway uh this paper by Caro and
colleagues they identified that
compensation levels did seem to vary
based on BMI
and what they found was when they looked
at people at the 10th percentile of BMI
so people with low BMI values the
compensation uh value that they
calculated was around 29 30 give or take
when they looked at the 90th percentile
of BMI so higher BMI values uh the
compensation value was all the way up
around 46 percent uh so it was a
meaningful BMI related uh difference in
terms of the compensation value but
the question about BMI is really
challenging
um I'm not quite certain what to do with
it practically speaking because when we
look at an observational relationship
like this where BMI seems to be
predictive of compensation values
there are a few things that could be
going on so so for example
um
a question you might ask is you know is
high exercise energy compensation a
hereditary characteristic that
predisposes someone to developing a
higher BMI or does the development of a
higher BMI somehow increase exercise
energy compensation it's kind of a
chicken and egg scenario and an
observational study like this doesn't
really give us an opportunity to answer
that with with a high degree of
confidence
um
one possibility you know someone might
also ask is it possible that energy
compensation estimates might be to some
extent distorted by the fact that BMI
fails to distinguish between fat mass
and fat free Mass uh which which
obviously fat-free mass is far more
predictive of resting energy expenditure
uh that is possible some of these
studies try to to go in and account for
that uh statistically but it is
something that muddies the water a
little bit when we when we try to make
when we try to take that BMI information
and kind of extrapolate to body fat
percentage or something like that
um another question that I think is is
is a really important question is
is it possible that people with higher
bmis
in these studies are simply more likely
to be intentionally restricting energy
intake such that the observed effect of
BMI is actually more related to the
current state of energy balance to me
that is a really important potential
confounder that you know when we look at
these huge sets of data is it possible
that people with higher bmis are more
likely to be doing physical activity for
the purpose of weight reduction or or
they they might be simultaneously trying
to establish an energy deficit so it's
very possible that the BMI effect could
be really just showing us what was
previously discussed in that Willis
paper which is that higher compensation
values are observed in negative energy
balance yeah it's like the classic
finding that uh the people who consume
more diet sodas tend to have higher bmis
but it's like yeah the the diet sodas
aren't causing that like they're go
they're going out of their way to drink
diet soda because they're trying to lose
weight yeah yeah so so I presented some
questions here that are worth
consideration that I simply don't have
the answers to
um but the ones I presented so far are
are kind of uh specific here's a vague
one that is still applicable it's still
a very valid question which is could
there simply be other behavioral
characteristics that just distinguish
individuals with low bmis from
individuals with higher bmis such that
the observed effect of BMI is driven by
something else entirely with this type
of observational approach so far like I
said it's the best data that we
currently have but there are inherently
limitations to the types of conclusions
we can draw so when it comes to the BMI
effect I'm simply not that certain about
what to do with it it's something that
I'm monitoring really closely whenever a
new study comes out I got my hopes up
this past month there was a study that
came out that looked like maybe it would
it would provide some additional Insight
but unfortunately it just didn't get at
the question the way I was hoping it
would and so for now uh the BMI
relationship exists it's something
that's out there but in terms of
practical application it's it's one that
we simply don't know what to do with but
what we can say with a decent amount of
certainty so far based on the evidence
is that the degree of compensation
doesn't appear to be dictated by
biological sex definitely seems to
depend on activity level and does seem
to be related to current the
individual's current state of energy
balance I can I can tell you what my
hunch is for the BMI thing as someone
who does uh certainly have plenty of
experience with uh with both being fat
and just being very different sizes
throughout my life
um I mean I I think that that first
thing you you threw out uh is high
exercise energy compensation a
hereditary characteristic or does the
development of obesity somehow increase
compensation
I suspect it's probably both
um like that that's like I certainly
have uh hereditary factors working
against me
um and even when even when like I I am
or have been smaller like uh a thing
that people tell me is like oh man like
I can go for a jog in the morning and
like I feel great that just energizes me
for the rest of the day and whenever
someone says that to me I'm like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
um you know I'm not denying their
experience but I can tell you good and
well I have never had that experience in
my life uh if I do any exercise
whatsoever even if I'm already in good
shape it it doesn't have an energizing
effect like I just I just want to chill
the rest of the day
um or or at least chill more than I
otherwise would have but then also the
impact of that is also influenced by how
large I am at the time like when I am
smaller uh exercise just doesn't take it
out of me as much the same way
um so yeah like I think that there that
that is always just kind of like a
factor in the background based on just
some hereditary characteristics I'm
dealing with
um but I also think that that for for me
personally like my exercise energy
compensation is a lot higher when when
I'm heavier than when I'm not yeah
that's an interesting observation and
there
you know
we follow the research more closely than
the typical person
um because every month we're going
through the journal Sweep with hundreds
of studies and just keeping an eye on
what people are doing I would say that
this particular question is on my very
short list of of research questions that
I'm eagerly trying to chase down
um I I really hope that people will get
at this from creative ways you know like
take really creative approaches I think
one thing that comes to mind is like it
would be interesting to expand upon your
anecdote with even just some qualitative
research uh getting groups of people
with very different body sizes and
weight histories and just saying what is
your experience with exercise you know
like I mean how does it impact your
energy level the rest of that day that
week how does it impact uh appetite
responses like I do think that that's a
really valuable uh it's it's an a
valuable opportunity where quali
research could really help dictate how
to get at it in the future
experimentally yeah um and I I'd like to
just broadly see more qualitative
research in our field I think
I know that uh James Steele's group has
done a few qualitative studies recently
um and I that that's a trend that I very
much like I hope that people will will
carry that forward Israel Halperin and
his and his collaborators they they do
some qualitative work too right yeah
yeah it's it's a lot of people
um when they see a qualitative study
they kind of have a double take if
they're not used to that whole world of
research but but it can really help fill
in gaps and and guide a lot of uh
hypothesis generation for sure yeah and
I mean if we just ignore qualitative
research there there is a
just large a breadth of human experience
that is difficult to quantify and like
Newtons or inches or kilograms or
whatever
um
that yeah like if if we don't have
quality like if if we don't have
qualitative research or just like ignore
the qualitative research we're
essentially closing ourselves off from
like a pretty large proportion of the
total questions that could be asked and
tentatively answered by research yeah
for sure uh so moving on we've talked
about all this exercise energy
compensation stuff it seems interesting
um but it's kind of hard to put that
into action you know you have to do a
lot of calculations and kind of make a
lot of estimates about what this value
should be and that value should be so
that is why we developed a tool to help
with this so I'll link it in the show
notes if you go to macrofactorapp.com
exercise calorie calculator with a
hyphen between uh all those those three
words there it'll take you to a
calculator that estimates the net impact
of a specific exercise bout on your
total daily energy expenditure so it
will be customized to your body size the
modality of exercise the duration of and
the intensity of exercise and we will
also uh basically do a a prediction of
your compensation value based on the
characteristics that We Gather in this
tool so we ask you kind of a short
series of questions use that information
to determine things like your most
likely resting energy expenditure your
most likely compensation value
um you know we we get the
characteristics of the exercise bout and
for the exercise bout uh what what we do
is we we pull met values from the 2011
compendium of physical activity by
Ainsworth and colleagues
um so that full compendium uh has like
over 800 types of exercise so I think if
people check out this tool they're going
to be very surprised to see the variety
of exercise modalities and intensities
uh that are represented within this tool
so you previously
um I I had made a little spreadsheet
available I didn't really talk about it
much but I made a little spreadsheet and
it was like well you have to go find the
net value of your exercise and you have
to go tell me what you think your
compensation value is and stuff like
that it just wasn't very user friendly
which is why I didn't talk about it much
it was like Hey this exists but there's
a lot of footwork that you have to do
yourself yeah
um in this instance you just click the
link answer some really basic questions
about yourself and uh and it helps you
out so
obviously people are going to be
critical and say oh you're just trying
to you know push this thing it's totally
free
You couldn't possibly make us any richer
by using this so this isn't like a big
advertisement this is just an area of
research I've been following closely and
we're pretty stoked to be able to put
together a tool that that we think is
pretty helpful here yeah because I mean
like this is I mean
this concept isn't totally novel like
there there are like exercise
calculators out there that you can find
um but the the I haven't seen another
one that gives any sort of guidance
about what amount of compensation you
should expect so they they kind of they
seem to tacitly operate on the additive
model or just kind of like hope that you
know what to do with it like if you uh
like go on a run and it says like oh
yeah you probably burn like 350 calories
on that run
and it's like well what should you do
with it like how much should that impact
your dietary targets how much is that
likely to impact your total daily energy
expenditure
who knows like you could look through
the research for yourself and like try
to make some estimates uh but this
calculator is novel in the sense that
like it it does all of that leg work for
you based on based on the research that
we have and what we do currently know
about energy compensation
um instead of just kind of spitting out
how many calories it expects you have
burned in the training session itself or
the exercise session itself it estimates
what that likely net impact is on your
total daily energy expenditure and the
thing I love about it the most is it
actually gives like a probable range for
where those
Those comp for like where those
compensation values might fall
we need ranges on a lot more things in
this world folks uh especially if you're
if you're predicting something or
estimating something
um like I understand why people do this
and I'm not I'm not faulting anyone for
it like it's it's a lot easier for any
sort of just like web app or whatever to
just like do some math and spit out a
single number that looks like a very
precise Point estimate
um and it's a lot harder to kind of like
deal with the logic on the back end to
like present things as a range in the
first place uh so I I don't think
anyone's trying to be like dishonest uh
or trying to mislead people but I do
think a lot of just online calculators
that exist for all sorts of things do
give people uh sometimes like an
excessive
um illusion of precision yeah about the
calculations they're doing where if
something says like dude you're burning
437.6 calories you're like holy [ __ ]
like if you got that decimal in there
man it it must be that or something
extremely extremely close to it but no I
mean anything like this
um
it's a it's an estimate like it's an
approximation at best so any any
estimate there is like
an inherent implied range of variability
around that point estimate uh and this
calculator actually makes it explicit
which uh I think is very nice yeah I
think you know like you said there are
other exercise energy expenditure
calculators that exist
um but but they basically have three
three things that I would view as
shortcomings or maybe we're just doing a
different thing than what they're doing
but uh like you said they don't reflect
the level of precision very well
um they they just give you a single
number they don't really give you a
range to help you understand okay I know
this isn't exact but what what's the
realistic probable range we're talking
about here so that's one shortcoming
another thing is that they they don't
frame it relative to your predicted
resting energy expenditure and the
reason that matters is because if you
were not exercising you would still
exist
um so so the question is not how many
calories did I burn during that session
but how many more did I burn versus an
alternate reality where I was just
hanging out sitting around you know so
so the added component is important
there
um and then another element like you
said is they don't take any effort to
deal with the the concept of energy
compensation which again as we've talked
about it's not a hundred percent but
it's certainly not zero percent in the
vast majority of cases either
um so yeah I think people listening
might say okay that sounds good
it sounds like you've improved upon an
idea that previously existed but you
might be wondering why this would
actually be useful
um aside from just being interesting so
there's three use cases that come to
mind for me uh the first one most
straightforward based on some of the
research we've talked about previously
this calculator makes it easier to
incorporate exercise changes into a
weight loss program or a weight gain
program but basically it helps you say
okay I'm changing up my exercise how
might I change up my nutrition in order
to accommodate that while I'm I'm
pursuing some kind of weight related
goal whether it's weight loss weight
gain weight maintenance
um so so this uh helps you make since it
is focusing on the net impact on total
daily energy expenditure it's a much
more tangible way to make those kinds of
decisions about how you can adjust your
diet to accommodate these exercise
changes
um a second potential use case maybe
you're just cruising toward whatever
body composition goal that you have in
mind but there's some atypical exercise
bout that pops up right so like maybe
you're gonna do uh like a charity run or
you're gonna accompany a friend on like
a pretty tough hike
um and you're like okay I want to
account for that with with my dietary
intake you know I like the rate of
weight change I'm experiencing and I
just want to keep it going so I want to
make sure I'm I'm accommodating this
unexpected increase in expenditure now
of course
a one-off exercise bout like this is not
going to derail your long-term efforts
whether you're trying to gain lose
maintain weight uh but some people
simply want to uh some people just feel
better about saying okay I I feel like
I'm taking some proactive step to kind
of study the ship here and keep my
energy availability relatively constant
rather than having this huge variation
where where this one day I'm in an
unusually large deficit right so that
that's a very justifiable uh use case
for this another one would be
um you know maybe you're gearing up for
an anticipated change in your exercise
habits and you just want to be proactive
about ensuring that you're actually
fueling those efforts you know so maybe
you're really kicking up your training a
notch or you know maybe you're going to
do like a charity run and you're going
to start a training program for it and
you're like I just want to make sure
that I am fueling those workouts
effectively and that as I ramp up my
physical activity here that I'm going to
be you know adequately fueled for
workouts and adequately recovering from
from them as well you want to make sure
that you're not under eating relative to
your change in exercise and so so this
gives you a tool that helps you do that
in a way that's really personalized and
you know these predictive equations like
I said are going to be completely
tailored to your situation which is very
different from just relying on some
heuristic that says oh yeah running
generally Burns about this many calories
or something like that so um what I'm
going to do is on the screen on YouTube
if I can figure out the technology I'm
going to actually show an example here
uh so basically you can go into this
Tool uh and it's going to ask you to
select a type of exercise right and so
for this example I'm going to put in
cycling as the prompt here and I'm going
to scroll down and find a Stationary
bicycling and I'm going to do that at 90
to 100 Watts so maybe I've got like one
of those uh you know stationary bikes
that shows me my wattage on the screen
as I'm pedaling and I'm planning to be
90 100 Watts but of course if you open
up the tool and look at the the
different exercises available there is a
huge variety it's not like everything is
going to make you calculate a watt value
some of it is very very real world in
terms of how it describes the exercise
some of it is more quantitative like
this particular selection so you're
going to choose the exercise type and
confirm it then you're going to type in
the duration in minutes so we're going
to say 30 minutes of cycling in this 90
to 100 watt range you're going to put in
your body weight for this example will
say 70 kilograms that's kind of the the
most generic body weight you'll ever
find in the research it's always a 70
kilogram person uh body fat percentage
let's say 15 but as you can see
hopefully on the screen the tool does
provide some um some visuals to kind of
help you
broadly assess where your body fat
percentage might be and this doesn't
have to be exact you just have to get
within a you know within hopefully a few
percentage points either way it doesn't
have to be precise just want to get in
the ballpark there close only counts for
horseshoes hand grenades and also this
uh this exercise energy expenditure
calculator absolutely as the as the
popular saying goes absolutely and then
now uh what we're going to do is uh
indicate whether we're gaining losing or
maintaining weight currently because
like we said previously uh you know
current energy status can be a pretty
important factor so for this example I'm
going to say I'm maintaining weight so
I'm in neutral energy balance relatively
speaking it's going to ask how many
training sessions I I typically do per
week
um and this isn't specific necessarily
to this exercise bout it's just your
general training habits overall so I'm
going to say I train one to three
training sessions per week throughout a
typical week and it's also going to ask
me about my general Act activity level
so for this example let's say that I
walk somewhere between five thousand to
fifteen thousand steps per day that
would put me in the moderate activity
level category so I'm going to select
that and if you don't know how many
steps per day you take that's totally
fine those are just to kind of help
people get kind of get a general Vibe of
how these categories work but but you
basically can make your own assessment
about generally speaking outside of the
gym outside of structured exercise uh
your your non-exercise activity level
day-to-day are you typically pretty
sedentary pretty active or kind of
moderate or somewhere in the middle so
you're going to type in those things
pretty simple pretty easy to use and
it's going to tell me that
my added energy expenditure from
exercise after accounting for
compensation is 136 kilocalories but the
probable range is somewhere in the
ballpark of 78 to 194 calories so uh
this is how the tool works again this is
trying to assess the net impact on total
daily energy expenditure which can be
very very informative for the variety of
use cases that I mentioned the last
thing I want to mention though here is
there is one use case that I would very
strongly in no uncertain terms
discourage there's one way that I really
don't want to see people using this tool
I have no way of knowing if anyone uses
it for this but I would really
discourage people from using this tool
for one specific thing so Halloween is
coming up in the United States oh yeah
uh it is a candy driven holiday and
Thanksgiving is coming up as well
believe it or not it kind of snuck up
this year as it does all years but
within the next six six weeks we're
gonna have two very food focused
holidays uh in the United States and a
lot of well-intentioned Fitness
enthusiasts and fitness professionals
and influencers on the internet are
going to talk a little bit about yeah
they're going to post about how oh if
you have two fun-sized Kit Kat bars
here's how many miles you have to walk
to offset that or here's how many
minutes of circuit training you have to
do to burn off those calories how many
licks does it take to get to the center
of a Tootsie Pop I have no idea but
here's how many jumping jacks you would
need to do to make up for it exactly so
so that is a genre of Fitness content
that is going to hit the internet pretty
hard uh over the next six weeks or so
um and people are going to start kind of
reinforcing this idea of making these
transactional deals where you're trading
exercise in order to afford some kind of
food you know whether it's you know
mashed potatoes on Thanksgiving or a fun
size Reese's cup on on Halloween so
people are going to be reinforcing this
idea that you have to earn calories or
that you have to trade exercise in order
to justify eating calories uh that is
completely antithetical to everything
that that we believe about eating and
exercise it reinforces some really
problematic perspectives about food and
exercise it uh is based on the
literature pertaining to the psychology
that goes into eating behaviors it's
just bad news in every possible sense
okay so we absolutely don't enforce that
we we don't uh support or reinforce that
kind of perspective about the
relationship between food and exercise
if you want a candy bar eat a damn candy
bar you know there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that you don't have to
justify it you don't have to you know
cross off some list and say yeah I did
146 jumping jacks or whatever
calculation you find uh we we want to
completely separate ourselves from that
perspective and I would really
discourage using this particular tool to
try to do any kind of transactional
bargaining where you say okay
I've decided that you know tonight I'm
gonna have this 300 calorie kind of
hedonic deviation so let me go and kind
of mess around with this calorie
calculator and see what I got to do to
make up for that I I just would strongly
discourage people from doing that
because that's no way to live and based
on the research it's also no way to view
food or exercise yeah it's a radical
perspective but it's fine to simply
enjoy things right I I think that uh I
think that like the the Protestant
um like the Puritan ethos is just like
deeply infected the American mind
um like to an extent where like it
applies to even people who wouldn't
consider themselves like particularly
puritanical where there's this idea I
think some people have where if you if
you enjoy something too much like if
something's too good
it's got to be bad right in some way
like it has to be perhaps sinful uh in
like the original conception and so you
either need to have like guilt or shame
attached to it or you need to like
self-flagellate and do some sort of
penance like in this case like X number
of sit-off sit-ups to like burn off that
uh that Hershey's bar or whatever
um
and like yeah like you just don't have
to it's it's fine to just enjoy things
have a good time
um and especially since their holidays I
mean Halloween comes around once a year
Thanksgiving comes around once a year
um it is it would be virtually
impossible to do so much damage on those
days that it uh significantly derails
you from whatever goals you're pursuing
the other
363 days out of the year so yeah yeah
it's fine like just just have fun enjoy
yourself
um don't don't come to this calculator
on November 1st and try to figure out
what what you got to do to pay off the
debt yeah I mean you know
mathematical estimates of the energy
cost of storing a new kilogram of fat
you know somewhere in the ballpark of 9
400 kilocalories so yeah doing the
calculus for the fun size KitKat bar is
psychologically not ideal and
physiologically Irrelevant in the long
run for your body composition goals and
one more thing uh one of the one of the
very fun things about macro factor that
that I think is super cool is the
Thanksgiving thing so oh yeah with AI
described within it you can you can kind
of speak into the phone microphone and
kind of report your food that way and
you you can basically just say like is
it Thanksgiving or is it Thanksgiving
dinner
um it is Thanksgiving dinner yeah so if
you just say Thanksgiving dinner it'll
actually give you like a pretty
representative meal for Thanksgiving
dinner that you can log so that way you
can be like okay like
um generally you know keeping my finger
on the pulse here but I'm having a low
stress enjoyable food-centered holiday
that doesn't have any you know any uh
guilt or shame associated with it and
you don't have to walk around and say
hey Grandma
um can I weigh the the cranberry sauce
when you're not using it yeah it's it's
a recipe that we that we get from the uh
nutrition X Library composed of uh
several of their common food entries six
ounces of turkey a cup of mashed
potatoes with gravy half a cup of
stuffing half a cup of sweet potato
casserole half a cup of green bean
casserole quarter cup of cranberry sauce
a dinner roll teaspoon of butter and a
slice of pumpkin pie that's like what
what goes into just like the general uh
uh entry here for Thanksgiving dinner
it's like 700 or 1760 calories which I
don't know that that feel that feels
about right
um
and yeah if you eat a little more than
that a little less than that if there's
uh some degree of tracking error even
like a reasonably significant degree of
tracking error for just like one meal
one day a year like ah just just relax
it's fine like that's that's not gonna
throw anything off yeah awesome well I
think that's all I got for this episode
do you have anything to to add or are we
good to go
um I have two things to add one uh
recording time right now an hour and 36
minutes so we did it uh We've we kept it
under two hours I'm I'm proud of us
unless unless Point number two is going
to take us 30 minutes no we'll see what
happens it won't uh I I just I just I
just want to Revel in this moment with
you here right now
um
actually came in close to 90 minutes
pretty good uh we don't have a a to play
us out segment generally anymore uh but
I'm I'm uh making an executive decision
to throw one in on this episode uh if
you
either already have an Apple TV
subscription or wouldn't have uh an
issue with getting one which I think
they have a free trial and I think if
they don't it's like five bucks a month
like it's one of the cheaper streaming
services
um there was a show called bad sisters
that just had its finale uh last night
as of the time of recording so
um more than last night by the time this
episode actually comes out uh anyway it
it was a wonderful show just absolutely
delightful
um and just as a a media recommendation
I I would recommend checking it out it
was it was a very fun romp uh well while
we're doing to play us out stuff I have
a correction to make to my correction
earlier so I I'm doubly correcting here
uh when you were talking about the
scandal with fat bear week
um you know you had mentioned that Holly
had
gotten some very sketchy votes that were
eventually overturned and I said well
I'm seeing on the internet here that it
was actually Bear 435 we were wrong I
said 480 480 is Otis I knew that rookie
mistake it was 435 Holly yeah 435 Holly
um but but I think I said well no it
wasn't Holly it was this number it it
was 435 Holly
um but honestly I kind of like the idea
that I that I just stripped the name
Holly from it because in a competition
where only a handful of the bears
actually have humanish names uh I think
with this voter fraud Holly should be
stripped over title and I think she
should go back to Bear 435 so it was an
accident but I actually stand by it
which I do with in fact most of my
accidents so yeah she's back to 435. I
think that should generalize I think if
anyone ever loses any Vote or election
period they they're just stripped of
their name absolutely yeah so uh shame
on 435 Holly who is now simply bear
number 435 yep all right well that does
it with the uh for this episode as
always thank you so much for listening
and we will be back soon with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]